years of like child stars
getting like bullied in school oh yeah i
did for sure oh you got bullied in
school because you were successful with
the show yeah middle school is really i
mean
elementary school people were rough but
it was like
stupid [ __ ] you know what i mean like
whatever making fun of your name or
maybe but but that was like across the
board everyone just you know made fun of
each other but i was with those kids for
a while
then you go to middle school and it's
like now you're dealing with kids from
you know five or six different
elementary schools that you haven't met
before and they're like
you know i would show up to school and
it was like i knew people either wanted
to be my friend because they were
impressed by me
or because
or just wanted to be around me to [ __ ]
with me
and you know i i remember
walking through the quad in like seventh
grade like the first week of school and
somebody just chucked an apple right to
the side of my head from across the bank
you know and they'd write [ __ ] on my
locker or like intentionally try and
trip me or like you know as you walk by
talk [ __ ] and i just learned to be like
[ __ ] you you know it gave me a real
thick skin so it prepared me well for
the internet that's for sure do you ever
get any fights
um are you a brawler or no not not until
later not till later but yeah
yeah i've had a few i mean that was
definitely more when i was just like
in my
addiction and drinking and being an
[ __ ] yeah you know i'm great for like
the first three hours and then after
that i'm like i will fight anyone for
sure
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude